コレはわざとじゃないんです・・・
深い理由があってこんなことになってます
僕は物を買うときamazonをよく使うんですけども
何かその、コンソメパンチの、このBIG BAG
これをちょっと買おうと思って
まあ、こう注文したと
とりあえず何かこんなに沢山
600個も買う予定なかったんですよ
その～、何だろ
とりあえずamazonでこれは
これ1つ(1袋)で1個じゃなくて
単位が12袋で1個なんですよ
12袋で1個。
でなんか頭イカれてたんだか知らないですけど
12袋ってこと知らなくて
いや、でも知ってたのかな・・・？
12袋でこれを5個注文して
多分60袋買おうと思ってたんですよ
5個 頼むところの
「0」が1つ多くて
50個・・・
注文してしまいました・・・
ぐふぅw
で、何かamazonさんから変なメールが来て
何か数量が多すぎぃて、何か
分けての配達になりますが送料に問題ありません
ありがとうございます、みたいな奴が来て
何かおかしいなと思ったんですけども
まあよく見返してみると
コンソメパンチを600個買ってました・・・
な、何で・・・「0」多かった・・・？
何かマネージャーさんにも相談して
その、ちょっとマジでヤバいっす、みたいな
ちょっと、俺んちにこのままじゃ
コンソメパンチが600個来るんで
ちょっと・・・マネージャー、ヤバいです
マジコンソメ600個来ます、みたいな
「コンソメ600（ロクゼロゼロ）」みたいな
ぐぐぅw
僕もね、困ったんすよ！
段ボール、バカでかいのたくさん来て
もうヤバかったんですよ
あの、マジ何かサイバーテロかと思って
何か、何？YouTuberディスってるアンチとかが
サイバーテロで俺のコンソメパンチ買うときに
何か「0」1個増やして送って
50×12で600のコンソメパンチ送ってやろうみたいな
分かりますか？
笑い事じゃないんです、これは
くすっw
いち個人として とても困ってて
そのマネージャーさんにも何か
「返品できます」って来たんですけど
俺は返品しないことを選びました
頼んだのは俺だし
サイバーテロではない・・・
ぐふっ...くくくw
サイバーテロではないから
俺のミスだと思って
俺はこのコンソメパンチを全て
うぅっぐふぅw
受け止めます。
でも、せっかくだし
プレゼント企画にしましょう！
（拍手）
これしかないでしょ！
ちょっとこれ合成じゃない、ガチだからね
ガチな方のコンソメパンチ600袋あるんですけども
登録者が100万人いったときも、プレゼント企画が
結局セグウェイがプレゼントできなかったんで
今回、なんと！コンソメパンチBIG BAGを
500袋プレゼントします！
（拍手）
100袋は俺の物だ。
いや、マジあの
ネタじゃないから！こんなのわざとしないからね！！
コンソメパンチ600袋買っても
何も起きないからね！マジで！
わざとじゃないのをちょっと理解して
5名の方に！コンソメパンチBIG BAGを
100袋プレゼントします
あ、応募する条件が2つあります
1つは、この、このチャンネルです
はじめしゃちょーの、このチャンネルを
チャンネル登録していること
それと
この動画の説明欄の応募フォームに
ちゃんと応募すること
この2つが条件です
この2つがコンソメパンチ100への近道でございます
今日から1週間後ですね
テロップで、この日の、この時間までに
応募してくださっwはぁ
なんかもう自分の画を見るだけで笑っちゃうんだけど
ちょっと僕のミスで
とんでもないことになったんですけども
やっとね、こうプレゼント企画ができるということで
まあ良かったのかなと思ってます
いや良くはないです！
ちょ、10万円・・・
コンソメパンチに10万円近くもってかれてるんで
僕はサイバーテロかとまだ疑ってます
超うめぇわ
というわけで、サイバーテロでコンソメパンチが
600袋届いたという動画でした！
じゃあな！！
144だ・・・144袋か、じゃあ
（全然来てなくね・・・？）
は、半分も来てないじゃん・・・
（それでコレでしょ？）
3倍くらいあるってこと？まだ
え、まだ全然来てないんだけど！
ねえねえねえマジか！！
（コレ600とか言っちゃったよ！）
あ、だからamazonからメール来たんだ！
（「分けて」って？）
なんかamazonから
その、多すぎるんで小分けして
日を別にして分けます、みたいな
まだ全然・・・w
（ろw600とか言っちゃったよ？）
これ600個・・・すいません訂正です
これ600個無くて、これがあと3、4回来ます。
えっ・・・サイバーテロじゃん
(へへへへへへww)
コンソメパンチ・・・えぇっ！？
マジで言ってんのか！